[Applauso]
le singolarità sono un concetto comune a
svariati fenomeni che vanno dalla
matematica la fisica la sociologia la
psicologia
ciò che accomuna questo concetto in
tutti i suoi svariati ambiti di
applicazione e che a piccolissime
variazioni di una grandezza
caratteristica possono corrispondere
enormi variazioni di tutte le altre sue
grandezze in matematica ad esempio una
discontinuità è un punto in cui la
funzione non è definita e nell'interno
della del quale la funzione può crescere
indefinitamente in fisica una
discontinuità gravitazionale è un
puntone all'interno del quale
l'attrazione gravitazionale tende
all'infinito un buco nero
se rappresentiamo lungo l'asse dei tempi
lo sviluppo della nostra civiltà
cosa che io ho fatto in questa scheda
per un breve intervallo di tempo partire
dal 1900 le singolarità tecnologica sono
quegli eventi in cui si compie una
innovazione radicale capace di
accelerare il progresso così tanto che
non siamo capaci di comprendere né di
prevedere le implicazioni ci sono un
paio di congetture che aiutano a capire
un fenomeno che stiamo vivendo una è la
famosa legge di moore e l'altro alle
regine kurzweil sulla crescita
esponenziale dello sviluppo tecnologico
ma mettiamo le da parte proviamo a
intuire il significato e il senso di
questo fenomeno per poterlo fare la
soluzione migliore dare un occhiata all
intervallo temporale che intercorre tra
le principali singolarità tecnologica
partiamo ad esempio dalla invenzione
della lampadina a incandescenza thomas
edison 1879 90 anni dopo nel 1969
missione apollo 11
l'uomo per la prima volta mette il piede
sulla luna 22 anni do anni dopo nel 1991
tim berners lee crea il world wide web
nove anni dopo
per la prima volta viene mappato il
genoma umano non servono leggi per
intuire che la distanza temporale tra le
principali singolarità tecnologica si
sta accorciando con una velocità
vertiginosa
ebbene tutto questo sviluppo ci ha visti
dare per scontate le risorse a nostra
disposizione ci sono le usiamo in
effetti in quanto anello di un
ecosistema molto più complesso
finora siamo stati piuttosto
indisciplinati e continuiamo a rompere
l'equilibrio con la natura ora non è mia
intenzione discutere qui delle
correlazioni fra l'inquinamento e i
cambiamenti climatici sono già in tanti
a farlo però mi si conceda di
condividere un esempio la plastica è
stata inventata in italia giulio natta
1954 ha creato il polipropilene
certamente una singolarità tecnologica
fondamentale è bene che ne è stato da
quell'invenzione che non è accorsa tanto
tempo fa alla fine dei conti che ne è
stato di tutta la plastica che da allora
abbiamo prodotto consumato e dismesso
secondo le stime di greenpeace e il 91
per cento di tutta la plastica prodotta
dall inizio è stata scaricata
direttamente nelle discariche a cielo
aperto è stata sotterrata o scaricata
nei mari che sia davvero la plastica il
problema ci stiamo sviluppando ad un
ritmo che non è compatibile con le
possibilità offerte ci dalla natura di
rigenerare le risorse che che consumiamo
negli ultimi 50 anni l'economia globale
si è sviluppata di un fattore 5 la
nostra capacità di produrre cibo è
cresciuta di un fattore due e mezzo il
nostro consumo di acqua potabile è
cresciuto in un fattore due il numero di
frammenti di plastica che galleggiano
sulla superficie del mare supera il
numero di forme di vita che si stima
vivano all'interno del mare
di 6 a 1 la plastica fa la più gran
parte dell'immondizia che scarichiamo al
mare circa il 90 per cento sono
approssimativamente 18.000 scaglie di
plastica 18 mila frammenti di plastica
per chilometro quadrato
il problema non è la plastica il
problema è l'uso che ne facciamo della
plastica uso che peraltro incide sulla
nostra salute
tra le varie sostanze che compongono la
plastica ad esempio c'è il bisfenolo che
viene rilasciato dalla plastica viene
assorbito dal nostro corpo
altra gli ormoni e distruggere
l'apparato endocrino e badate bene la
plastica costituisce solo il 12 per
cento del nostro rifiuto solido urbano
indifferenziato
ancora una volta la plastica non è il
problema
il problema sta nella nostra incapacità
di gestire in maniera inefficiente o
meglio efficiente ed efficace di rifiuto
indifferenziato ora certamente si fa un
gran parlare del problema associato
all'inquinamento e al rifiuto e la
sensibilità alla consapevolezza sta
crescendo su scala globale come
opportuno che sia dato che è globale e
la natura del problema ma questo non è
non può essere sufficiente a
indirizzarlo e men che meno a risolverlo
secondo recenti recenti stime di
worldwide bank worldwide group la nostra
produzione annua globale di rifiuto
solido indifferenziato urbano passerà
dalle attuali due miliardi di tonnellate
a 3.4 miliardi di tonnellate
da qui al 2050 si tratta di un
incremento del 70 per cento ora siamo in
molti a ritenere che per quanta energia
si spenda effettivamente nel discutere
del problema certamente molto a meno
energia e investita nella discussione
del dominio delle soluzioni e che sia
giunto il momento per le competenze di
cui disponiamo per indirizzare delle
soluzioni che ci consentono da un lato
di recuperare l'equilibrio di cui
parlavamo prima con la natura e
dall'altro di rendere la nostra presenza
su questo pianeta più sostenibile
pensiamo che sia giunto il momento di
lavorare insieme per sviluppare delle
soluzioni che siano le nuove singolarità
tecnologiche quelle che ci dovranno
consentire di indirizzare il problema
del trattamento del rifiuto solido
urbano indifferenziato su scala globale
possibilmente abbattendone l'impatto
sulle nostre vite e sulle
sull'ecosistema come ce la caviamo ad
oggi facciamo del nostro meglio
ad esempio con la raccolta differenziata
che facciamo partire dalle nostre case
pensiamoci bene però ogni volta che
dismettiamo un rifiuto di fatto stiamo
delegandone il trattamento alla pubblica
amministrazione che lo raccoglie lo
porta distante da novi e noi ce ne
dimentichiamo
e di fatto siamo sotterrando nascondendo
il problema sotto il tappeto a pensare a
pensarci bene per certi versi quando
differenziamo un rifiuto siamo in realtà
complicando il processo di trattamento e
di smaltimento
vedremo in considerazione una comune
bottiglia di plastica per l'acqua è
fatta di tre può essere fatta fino a tre
tipi di pasticche diverse un processo di
trattamento efficiente di questo tipo di
rifiuto necessiterebbe che noi nelle
nostre case separassimo in maniera
distinta il tappo
il corpo è l'etichetta sono tre tipi di
plastiche diverse peraltro con tre
valori economici diversi e questo tipo
di complessità si può applicare a
svariate sottocategorie di rifiuto
rifiuti che poi sono raccolti i momenti
diversi da automezzi diversi
specializzati per tipologia che li
trasportano verso impianti remoti
anch'essi specializzati per tipologia di
rifiuto dove vengono trattati con
un'efficienza certamente inferiore al
100 per cento quindi uno sforzo
incredibile che peraltro ogni anno ci
porta a produrre 1.6 miliardi di
tonnellate di biossido di carbonio a
fronte lo ricordo dei due miliardi di
tonnellate di rifiuto solido urbano
quindi per trattare in maniera
inefficiente rifiuto produciamo in peso
quasi tanta anidride carbonica quanto è
il peso del rifiuto che tratta
con l'aggravante che fin dalle nostre
abitazioni
siamo noi a lavorare in supporto di un
processo che è complesso ed inefficiente
quindi l'uomo al servizio di una
tecnologia inefficiente non avrebbe
senso che fosse la tecnologia al
servizio dell'uomo
io collaboro allo sviluppo di un
progetto di start up noi reputiamo che
il concetto di usa e getta sia un
aberrazione culturale che ereditiamo dal
passato che non ci possiamo più
permettere e di cui ci dobbiamo liberare
per questo motivo abbiamo progettato un
macchinario di dimensioni ridotte che
nasce con lo scopo di accogliere rifiuto
indifferenziato tritarlo riducendone il
volume di oltre il 90 per cento generale
scaglia di materia prima che possano
essere impiegate in maniera sostenibile
nei processi di trasformazione
industriale
usiamo la luce e l'intelligenza
artificiale per riconoscere
automaticamente i materiali di cui sono
composti i nostri rifiuti e per
separarli
il fatto che le dimensioni del
macchinario siano ridotte per altro ci
consentirebbe di mettere in opera questa
tecnologia non più a valle di una
filiera lunga complessa inefficiente ma
a monte ovvero il più possibile in
prossimità degli esseri umani cioè
laddove i rifiuti sono generati sono
prodotti se fossimo in grado di fare
questo allora potremo realizzare dei
benefici l'importanza incredibile
potremmo certamente abbattere il costo
della filiera tradizionale ovvero dei
flussi di raccolta trasporto e
trattamento specializzato potremmo
abbattere di quasi un ordine di
grandezza alle emissioni di anidride
carbonica e potremmo generare una fonte
di valore economico per certi versi
anche sorprendente il nostro obiettivo è
niente più sprechi perché nel nostro
punto di vista i rifiuti non sono lo
scarto del nostro sviluppo
il residuo del nostro essere in vita su
questo pianeta
i rifiuti sono una risorsa che deve
essere valorizzata ad essere
capitalizzata
ora io sono qui oggi in rappresentanza
di un po tutte le start up che operano
in questo settore che fanno ricerca e
sviluppo in questo settore per fare un
appello
l'industria consolidata non è nuova alla
realizzazione di innovazione così
radicale
le tecnologie ci sono e questa
competenza si può dominare potremmo
davvero portare il trattamento
industriale dei rifiuti a monte della
filiera vicino agli esseri umani per
sollevarne il peso del proprio sviluppo
la domanda è ma perché a farlo dovrebbe
essere una start up
cos'è che manca per colmare quella
distanza che c'è tra a parlare di
ambiente di sostenibilità e fare
qualcosa di deciso per realizzare una
concreta inversione di rotta questa
nostra tecnologia deve essere completata
il nostro è un appello a svilupparla
insieme cosa serve servono
consapevolezza e coraggio
imprenditoriale
serve una visione responsabile sul
futuro associata alla ferma volontà di
realizzarla concretamente questa visione
superando la distanza che c'è tra il
dire e il fare ci rivolgiamo nello
specifico a tutte quelle aziende che
operano nel settore del trattamento del
rifiuto delle materie prime noi stiamo
realizzando quella ricerca e sviluppo
che voi avreste potuto compiere e in
passato
se ciò non è avvenuto fino ad ora il
momento giusto affinché ciò accada
e adesso noi e tutti gli altri che
operano in questo ambito
siamo pronti a condividere i brevetti la
proprietà intellettuale
i prototipi tutte le cose che abbiamo
imparato compiendo montagne di errori e
risolvendoli parliamoci collaboriamo
facciamolo insieme grazie per il tempo e
soprattutto per l'attenzione
[Applauso]